thank you for coming guys I know this on
the videos screen there's folks
- thank you for having me
I'm here to talk about cybersecurity is
quite large topic and I'm Fleming Shi
from Barracuda Networks let's get
started we will do a quick introduction
of Barracuda Networks a little
background of our company and what we
have done in the last 15 16 years so
started from 2004 to 2008 you probably
saw some ads in airports Berg basically
comes in as appliance leader we actually
built application layer security
appliances these applications layer what
I mention is OS i7 so SMTP protocol
which is a application protocol allows
you to transmit emails right then
HTTP is another one that we actually did
a lot of work on so we actually built
quite a few security appliances at that
time and in fact because we didn't want
to just get stuck on just email
anti-spam products with literally two or
three different products and that helped
us move very quickly because we had a
unified form and configuration
management kind of framework so we
became the unit volume leader for
purpose-built security appliances and
you know study done by IDC and 2009 to
2010 you guys remember hackers
virtualization everyone loved it so
purpose-built hardware it's kind of you
know wasn't the right way to deliver
things so we actually virtualized our
appliances and we supported VMware
hyper-v various different KVM support
proxmox is one of those open source
hypervisor clusters that you can install
and we also added more product families
because Barracuda as I mentioned we were
starting with layer 7 SMTP HTTP so with
the Web Filter with it email security
then we got little bit even lower into
the OSI layers and we start to filter
network traffic and also we started
building data security and data put
protect protect and products like backup
right so instead of the good old days we
mean to take
then back then barracuda was the first
one to put all the data into a Princeton
we replicated into the cloud and web
application delivery and security is a
really interesting one because remember
you guys heard of load balancers anyone
it was really cool because the idea is
to make sure your your application runs
really high-performance and you can have
multiple actual real servers behind the
load balancer and the load balancer job
is to direct traffic so where could a
you know on top of the loop or actually
did start building security that web
application by the way this so web
application delivery and security is one
key area especially when we evolved it
further and evolved it into a way to
secure web applications I'll talk about
in a little bit so every day we're using
web applications right from banking from
shopping right from going to hospital
booking appointments all those things so
2011 to 2013 we actually start seeing
more people getting rid of their data
centers they just want to have nothing
to do with rack and stack so they just
wanted to consume software as a service
right so Barracuda actually start
building same set of security products
but making sure we can actually deliver
the same solution using a service mesh
that we we provide so the customer never
had to touch any box or any virtual
machine or deal with any wires or any
computer or anything like that they just
go ahead and assign Barracudas as the
email security service as to sorted
their next hop before they hit the
exchange server right so centralized
management for dispersed IT
organizations this is interesting okay
perfect is it better okay so this is
really interesting because it's
companies getting globalized they start
to have branches and offices in
different parts of the world so they're
there for the Barracuda appliances are
starting to protect multiple offices
across the world so we had to make sure
centralized management is in place like
control center cloud control appliance
control
gives us the ability to actually deliver
the policy and security they need
without getting each office to wake up
and do the do the right thing we
actually were able to deploy the policy
across the globe and public cloud
deployment started to emerge any of you
guys remember when did the AWS start
their first service in or Amazon start
their AWS service do you remember when
20 2006 actually it's quite long ago
yeah
the first service they offer is called
SQS it's a message bus it's a very
simple service if you're building your
program with message bus and having the
multiple publisher consumer kind of
model you would have enjoyed that
service and what's really cool is not
for a while people didn't take it
seriously because you know it's online
bookstore online shopping you know
shopping store and they have an
infrastructure to now host any
application right so but as things move
down people are starting to utilize it
security becomes a need and barrier
could have started to deploy our
solution in the cloud by the way
Microsoft Azure was second right there
and we were the first firewall ever
deployed in Microsoft Azure so in 2014
to 2016 I would say we have started to
do a lot of architectural enhancements
because even in my days when we were
building software most of the times
monolithic architecture right so
micro-services is starting to take off
in Barracuda because we wanted to
provide services to our install base and
also new customers so for example events
events persistent threat detection and
sandboxing this is something that you
can't really do on a physical box and
expect it to scale right you have to do
find a way to find compute that's more
elastic so you can identify threats and
and make sure everybody gets the benefit
whence the threat is detected link
protection that protects users at the
point of click is very important because
these days websites could be safe today
it could be totally normal you know even
government websites could be safe but if
there is a
durability and there could be a latent
threat to it somebody can actually
upload and inject a content into the
website a month later
then use that reputation of the website
and spread this the malware right so
it's important so at the point of click
so whenever you click we're protecting
you we're scanning that content no
matter one right that's the idea and IP
reputation domain reputation are very
useful because we can actually drive
efficiency at a lower level on OSI
layers to be able to detect bad stuff
and bad intent and one other thing we
did in architectural enhancement is API
first so we decided to build our
software every single product to go
through the API discipline so actually
the user interface is just a
representation of the API functionality
behind it what's good about that is it
allows other tool tools other dashboards
to integrate with our product right so
it's very very useful and other piece of
it is office 365 start start to take off
so it's less and less people use
exchange servers and more people are
using office 65 it's still growing at 30
percent every year it's massive right so
when nice thing about that is now office
365 is the SAS solution and using their
API is we were able to then look at
different threats and cloud native API
is for telemetry as well as
instrumentation is very important
because we can then drive certain
security protection very much native to
that platform let it be AWS or a sure
so 2017 - now what we're doing now is
we're continuing our architectural
enhancements because one of the key
things is you guys probably heard of
kubernetes it's an talker
these are containerized workloads so the
ability to actually run your software in
a container doesn't necessarily have to
be on virtual machine you actually can
be a physical box so any of you guys
remember Solaris I'm sure you guys so my
first container was zones remember so my
friends and I will be using a single
physical box but we all have our own
playground on that box and we're not
interrupting each other it's the same
idea
well what's being done now is the
software is not being packaged into
these containers and you can deploy it
anywhere right so Google has their
container service kubernetes service
then microsoft azure added kubernetes
service same thing as AWS and leveraging
AI and machine learning this is one area
I wanted to point out because just the
normal threats that we'd attack every
day I call it normal it's still very
very tough to detect especially advanced
persistent threat but what if email
doesn't even have a link in it doesn't
have attachment how do you identify the
bad intent right so you have to figure
out how to do machine learning and drive
that artificial intelligence to detect
those things so just a quick thing about
you know some samples of monolithic
applications used a barracuda example
here so front and back and middle layer
right so the persistent layer usually is
done in a database let it be a primary
secondary kind of replication usually
replicate all the time you know so in
this situation it's kind of being done
many times in the past or I'll call my
sequel IBM db2 any type of database
happens that way then the Model View
control user interface and control
frameworks that drives all the flow of
the applications sits in the front so
this this is the old architecture so
today a sample micro service will be
done this is actually a one example from
barracuda as well we use something
called a distributed database so it's
obviously API enables so every layer we
talk through API and message bus based
which allows you to like I mention like
sqs you can actually have many
publishers of messages and workloads and
many workers to consume those workloads
so you can have elasticity and rich cash
layer this is important because because
we're the the application usually is
very well distributed you have to have
locale look locally available caches so
actually you can respond on things very
quickly so this is important for threat
detection so Barracuda today we pass
roughly about two billion emails every
day so we have to move very quickly if
we identify something that's a threat we
want to make sure all the endpoints in
the service match is able to capture
very quickly right so caching is
important so the interesting thing about
distributed database you guys probably
heard of Cassandra it's very nice
database allows you to do eventual
consistency which means you don't have
to replicate all the time because you
replicate all the time you may not use
the data all the time if you have
sixteen sites it's very expensive on the
traffic so eventual consistency gives
you let's say you have a hundred nodes
you choose to replicate replicate to
three nodes to make sure it's stays so
it never lost that way you will never
have to replicate it other 97 and only
when a site is required that piece of
data then it will synchronize over at
that points the fourth right so you
think about that eventual consistency is
a really major efficiency driver so
micro services are built like this also
a little bit background the barracuda
ATP so as I mentioned events persistent
threat is one of the hardest things to
detect these are zero day threats one of
crys peteus all those guys are the you
know ever since the eternal blue leakage
there's many variants of that basically
rent somewhere and wiper where that's
basically it really hard to detect so
barracudas advanced persistent threat
detection layer with multi-layered so we
have static analysis heuristics
behavior analysis as well as sandboxing
right so so just wanted to give you this
background so when I jump into the
material later on you will see why it
matters okay so I'm gonna talk about
state of cybersecurity in my view in
five areas email web applications secure
connectivity cloud security which is
very interesting very different from no
more if you think of the classic it is
really just firewalls no it's really
different and also data goes horizontal
there's three different states of data
we gotta make sure we protect so many
many stats right you guys see it on the
newspaper every day just the other day I
heard about someone using a laser
pointer playing with all the smart
speakers was able to actually turn open
garages right and but anyway so every
day organizations like closed
30% of the organization's were infected
by ransomware a lot of folks in the you
know in the I think the first wave of
ransomware attack was attacking
consumers they were asking for pennies
right like $50 $100 or maybe just a
cryptic owing back in the days but it's
gotten much much worse
so starting with email I think you guys
know Maslow's hierarchy of needs right
so physics physiology you got to have
some place to live have water have drink
you know just being able to stay alive
safety is the next one feel secure right
financially and physically and
eventually love you got a community
feeling family friends and esteem and
eventually get to achieve great greater
things the reason I bring this up is
attacks to Barracuda through our eyes
are very similar so I joined Barracuda
in 2004 right this is literally 15 years
ago that time
remember spam spam was really paint
about everyone hated spam so just just
causing trouble right and also we we saw
that random attacks just you know as
just like Maslow's hierarchy it's
basically when you when you get better
in one thing you move on to the next
level you feel like you're have done
done the right thing so for the bad guys
they've done a lot of that rent random
attack first they eventually do smash
and grab basically find CVEs all the
vulnerabilities right if there's a
vulnerable web server what do I do I
figure out how to get in there and
identify all the other sites we are who
are not patched right in that situation
they can actually you know cause trouble
eventually very targeted attacks this is
spearfishing I think Andy mentioned that
he remembers spearfishing
as a word this is important because
spearfishing is really targeted attack
social engineered looking for ways to
actually gain your trust right and
eventually the worse than out of all is
basically a nation-state right
manipulation of you know using social
media and those kind of stuff so I'm
going to touch on this chart real quick
I did want to make sure the acronyms are
explaining so it doesn't look difficult
to read so you can see this is
logarithmic chart chart right here right
shows email being the first probably the
greatest attack surface right so the
number of attacks you can see BES s is
our email security service email
security gateway if you can look at this
data it's much longer and if you look at
logarithmically it's over hundreds
hundreds of thousands of threats were
saying and if you compare to other
attack surfaces there they're not
nothing but there they do happen but a
lot less than email so the reason I
wanted to talk about that is this
particular threat that we detected in
2017 you guys remember petia right so
petia the first appearance was March
2016 it's just a class of ransomware it
came out from eternal blue bleak so not
petia is basically happened like almost
a year plus later and idea here is I
want to talk about three different
attack surfaces that happen with this
particular threat so what does it do you
know the method of delivery for example
meat
Emme dark is a financial application
used by a lot of ukraine organizations
and also they deliver this threat
through email vector as well and the
trouble is it's not a good ransomware
there's no ransomware that's good by the
way
I'm the ransomware in this situation
actually failed it did not if you paid
the Bitcoin it will never give you the
file back it was actually broken it
erases your hard drive so unrecoverable
encryption and damages the system master
boot block as well as master file table
so this is a cert a screen that that
happened during the day of attack as you
can see there is attachment here right
this is the
request sort of for quote and this
particular file is it's actually
exploiting a remote script execution
kind of vulnerability in Windows it then
dump if you open it it would download a
spreadsheet that's press she has a
obfuscated JavaScript in it that would
then download executable eventually run
the PowerShell then eventually encrypts
your your system or and basically breaks
your your your filesystem
so I just want to make sure you guys
know this is from Ukraine at and then
this is the they're at their site and
that day through our system you can see
we actually I'm gonna jump to the next
page because it's much easier to read so
about obviously our time is a little
different because Pacific time so we had
over 300 I'm sorry 3287 blocks and we
saw this many hits and came from 413
locations in the install base right so
it's the same request for order you can
see that so the point there is that how
do we actually trigger it it's like how
do we trigger this is because we have a
set of units in the field we will be
immediately notified if the malware is
spreading right when we see that that
behavior were able to then extract the
document and make sure we we do a
sandbox analysis on it and make sure all
the other indicators related to this
particular threat is covered right so I
just want to point that out it's a it's
very everyday we see this kind of stuff
it happens so fast we have to really be
basically react very quickly so remember
the architecture that we put in place
needs to react in milliseconds in this
case it wasn't it was like 40 some
seconds or something 42 seconds right we
collected a whole bunch of actual
malware that's basically not petia so
this is the attack to which I called it
attack to which is the email attack
surface which is
pretty effective if you ended up opening
that file you will be attacked by not
petia right and the the next one I want
to talk about is this how does the
technology work so basically this is an
example of a mesg so in our email
security service the SAS solution you
replace everything in the blue box with
our SAS solution right in the ESG
scenario customer do have a physical box
or virtual machine so what we do is
basically email goes all the way from
here to to the email server which we are
actually a message transfer agent MTA
where our job is like a bumping the wire
so before exchange server gets it we get
the first view of it so in that gateway
scenario we obviously have various
different layers in in protection but
it's important to realize having a
gateway in front of your exchange server
or your officer c-5m s MX record allows
us to basically examined malware we take
the email apart the envelopes the
content and also the attachments we make
sure we scan them so that's the
technology and one thing I do want to
touch on these are the different files
that we see getting weaponized and the
biggest ones PDF actually gets a lot of
suspicious counts but you can see the
the office documents gets the most
actual malicious because they are much
easier to weaponize right you can put in
a macro inside of your spreadsheet you
can put PowerShell and all those things
in there of course email I would say
portable executable of course when you
when you see them the you know their
binaries right so that's an email but we
see a lot of them in in networking
Network firewalls so beyond picky
remember apt is advanced persistent
threats and fishing
here comes spear fishing spear fishing
is very different so I just wanted to
make sure we point it out contains links
to malicious sites for fishing but not
for spear
fishing it's just a piece of text right
it tries to gain your trust and fool you
and send too many people know usually
it's really send it to a very targeted
person and most of the time they want
you to transfer money or steal your
social security number so figure out
some way to get you to to give you give
them the credentials so spear phishing
is a big issue and the problem that's
why it's a big issue is it's really hard
to stop because imagine the earlier
section I mentioned the email security
gateway we are able to detect links and
scan the files in this case we can't
write so others it bypasses everything
right so what do you do in this case the
only way going about it is actually
figure out how to understand the
communication pattern between your
people right you know organization your
friends and if you're using the rest
signature sometimes like I use our CEOs
example people found out his name's
William Jenkins so so the bad guys
thought maybe I just signed the
signature William Jenkins
guess what Vijay never uses William
Jenkins he always uses BJ right or bill
B is so that yeah that's okay there's
there are other indicators I give you
other example when you look at who is
accessing the email who is sending the
email the sender information is very
important does BJ's an email from places
other than Silicon Valley or you know
it's very rare right can he be in two
places within five minutes of you know
of each other so so those are all the
data that we can use to actually
identify the behavior of the sender or
did the message you know the intent
right and also sometimes you look at
because every organization every company
has our almost half our executives all
on the website right people knows who is
the CFO who is the controller who is
right who's the legal department so a
lot of times that you utilize the social
engineered information to to actually
build to build the the actual weapon so
it's very important to actually use AI
here so the way we do that is we
obviously a very good partner with
Microsoft
so we act we actively work with their
api's to instead of using MTA in between
we're able to look at historical data
and actually understand the
communication patterns to understand the
right things right and who sends email
from where all that and that way we can
build a this is not unsupervised machine
learning this is supervised training so
we classify we utilize the right
information to make sure we train a
corpus of email train a model with the
corpus of email eventually use the model
and in real life so so that's that's
what we have done with Barracudas
products called Sentinel so now I jump
to web application Bengaluru India our
team is India so so a lot of times
people think you know web sites are all
protected with a firewall the firewall
it doesn't do it firewalls layer 3 4 it
can detect IP addresses domain
reputation DDoS maybe those right but
application layer requires a lot more
in-depth what kind of parameters the
application is taking in from the
internet who what kind of user agents
are coming to your website right so in
fact this is a scary number 10 percent
of all web applications are protected
only 10 percent are protected by a woth
so that means every day we're using
banks and travel agents and everything
we do online how are they protecting us
right we don't know so that's it that's
really a big problem even companies like
oh Koufax you guys remember that breach
they had WAAFs and they probably had a
sophisticated Wow but the problem is a
lot of times
so complicated if we don't configure it
correctly what does it do it breaks the
application so people are setting in to
audit mode other mode doesn't do
anything to protect you it just tells
you something went wrong after the fact
okay so so it's important to figure out
how to build a product that is actually
helpful easy to use and be able to
protect people right so it's the number
one attack vector leading to data
breaches by Verizon so back to this not
petia breach sorry the attack so this is
attack zero so the reason it's attack
zero is they someone had a sleeper cell
in me dock servers injected content into
the updates so which means when the
software does you know a lot of times we
set our software to auto update right
because you don't want to be bothered
when you use is hey if you want update
now you want to just auto update so the
problem with that is because they
figured it out so they basically changed
the content of the update right and
basically applied it with enough
malicious intent that basically did the
same thing it does with that email it
downloads and you know attacks your MBR
and MFT right so it's very important to
recognize this is attacks zero so
somebody went into the servers that the
guys that me talked didn't even know
that it happened then they just kept
cool and didn't want this do anything on
tier later off okay so like a sleeper
cell so so things we do this is
interesting so this is what I wanted to
show you so valve actually has what we
called a wasp with top ten and basically
provides various different kind of
protection there's many others
cross-site scripting injection contain
injection a lot of web servers actually
has issue with vulnerabilities they
allows you know privilege escalation
eventually content could be changed so
how does that technology work right so
this technology works as
verse proxy so reverse proxy is
basically sitting in front of your web
server it's job is to intercept the HTTP
request and HTTP request and job is to
actually analyze the request before it
goes into the real server right so and
what we have done again this is a very
highly intense workload so we we have a
solution actually running Microsoft
Azure so you de lysing that elasticity
so because web applications are
constantly gonna get bigger more users
are gonna use the apps and not just
users by the way a lot of times is API
is from your app on your phone it talks
behind the scene to the server in the
cloud right so we have to make sure this
kind of workload is protected so then
said secure connectivity so in many ways
my very first firewall is played around
with was Cisco pics you guys remember
that but in between I built my own Linux
firewall and played around and
eventually but secure connectivity is no
longer about firewalling firewall is
designed to block or do certain type of
ACLs in front of a set of computers
right or a network but secure
connectivity is about you can connect
anywhere between your cloud environment
let it be AWS different regions you SES
uswest to your office to your data
centers yet by the way that this this is
in Austria Innsbruck yeah yeah so that's
the secure connectivity story comes into
play here for the now petia story as
well because this is gonna be on quiz
later
this is attack one right so what it is
is what happens when the update comes
through it has to go through a bunch of
systems and networks if we if we had the
right solution in place it would have
actually stopped that particular update
right so I just want to make sure you
guys pay attention so that said all the
attacks related to not Patea these three
things I just want to make sure and
never
attack zero that's probably the most
dangerous one because all they have to
do is figure out a way some kind of
vulnerability to your server then they
start changing the content of your
updates and the update will still work
for your software they just added new
things to it yeah okay so so in a
scenario of
a secure connectivity or a firewall
product in the next-gen firewall what we
do is I use this web security gateway
example because this workload actually
lives in the firewall as well and we
also have a separate product for that
but what it does is it's a transparent
proxy so you can actually work off a
network just like normal Network you
have a router far away at the top then
basically in the logical breakout you
have a transparent proxy this is not a
reverse proxy this is a proxy that
basically reads all the incoming traffic
so the request that goes out it captures
it and on inside inside the network like
if your computer is doing an update it
will actually be captured by this
proxies service and it will do the scan
for you transparently so this is a layer
to bridge literally you have a basically
one LAN port basically connect each
other then it builds a TCP session on
top of that bridge and in this case it's
it's more of a single arm scenario most
of the networks are like this because
they don't want to have any bottlenecks
in between so you can have WC CP or
Cisco protocol to drive that web traffic
to the proxy so that's how that works
so so that said yeah this basically is
explaining so we also most of all the
products that we have also handle SSL so
we can make sure your user agents your
your your systems trusts the the device
we put in place as authorized basically
seiner certificate signer so then we can
actually look at inside the SSL traffic
ok
so I will TP on your household smart
devices that I mentioned actually IOT to
me
I have Alexa and those devices
- but I'm very cautious I usually turn
them off but if you look at it
millions of entry points the IOT like
Alexa I don't know if you guys remember
several months ago
someone's device actually start making
funny comments like the Koreans are
attacking did you guys remember that
yeah actually what happened was someone
hacked into that device and able to
actually replay you know changed the the
commentary right so the problem with
that is everything in IOT for households
are eventually connected to a set of
servers what happens if basically you
suddenly have a millions of doors and
that door can lead to somewhere else's
house right think about that so so as I
mentioned networking from home to a
species environment eventually the
central service then eventually to other
homes that's the danger industrial IOT
is quite different and industrial tea
actually as robotics right so we
actually support a lot of customers who
make cars and one of the important thing
about that is most of those robotics are
not new they have been around for many
years
they're running Windows 8 with some
older windows right and a software
that's designed for that robotics to
function normally they don't want to
change it for you know if it's not
broken it just does the right thing the
tricky part is it's vulnerable to whole
bunch of Microsoft vulnerabilities right
so like the SMB eternal blue
vulnerability it's obviously there for
these devices so what happened is when
someone captures the environment they
can actually get into industrial IOT and
mess up the production line right so so
again automated updates tricky most
people don't want update them to
software and it's because they don't
want to break their production line so
so that's it this is important to pay
attention to industrial tees because
from airplane makers to to car makers to
anybody who are using robots they're
likely running a really
version of windows like for us we would
never want to use Windows 8 or older
windows right it's usually something
that's doing things yeah so we have some
use cases I wanted to share with you
basically we edge devices predict for
maintenance other right things we do to
make sure we build a shield around that
industry IOT right that basically robot
you think of it even it's running a more
vulnerable operating system if you build
the right shield around it what we call
the secure connector sometimes we use
magnets to stick next to the robot and
so a actually protects the robots
communication several communication the
magnets is designed to mount our device
right on the robot yeah so we have that
option just see if you have project at
home you wanna fight with it you can use
that so in this case it's a US air
conditioning as a service you know
obviously we're inside here you can
probably see a little local right there
right so our job is to embedding to
these devices in the field right and
Barracuda I just want to touch on one
thing but I could have started building
the network firewall 15 years ago before
before it was a different company it was
an Austrian company we built that
product for ATM machines so which means
back in the days you have to have that
connectivity have to have to have
stability and resilience because the ATM
machines cannot go on communicated or
something cannot go wrong with it right
so the information has to flow correctly
so we build a protocol that's our own to
allow us to actually have multiple
media's to connect to that device so you
can even supplement it with the 3G back
in the days or 4G modem so you will
never lose connectivity so that's the
air conditioning use case smart the
power quit monitoring it's another I'll
call it basically managing devices like
if you think of all the generators
people are using these days
and you want to make sure they're secure
a lot of them are smarter than before
so it has a communication channel you
don't want anyone to tamper with that
smart city projects allowed us to do our
rollout cities where you have better
connectivity of the of the
municipalities so so the next one I want
to talk about is cloud so this is over
overly used word people call cloud
I caught a bunch of servers personally I
used used to build data centers so
servers well just going and really cloud
is other people's servers right that the
challenge here is that infrastructure as
a service is inherently very complex
because what they're trying to do they
were trying to automate deployment of
your workload so they're building a lot
of configuration and management playing
features to allow you to elastically
deploy and manage and configure and
visibility of assets is a problem
because now your server is no longer in
your data center or your own you know
control it's all over AWS all over a
treasure in multiple regions and if you
have a really successful service you're
likely going to have thousands if not
tens of thousands of systems right how
do you gain access to that and who is
using what who has access to what is
very important I am that's basically
access management identity access
management configuration drift is very
important because when people what you I
just threw out a question real quick how
many people know how many services are
in EWS today that native services AWS
offers roughly four forty five sixty
it's about 160 yeah and Microsoft Azure
is doing about 170 right the problem is
they every year you go to their their
event let it be
AWS reinvent or ignite they always have
new services the problem with these
services there's nothing wrong with them
there are all very nice services if you
know how to configure it correctly and
securely if you don't then what what's
going to happen
you're going to leave some open door for
example some quite sizable company
actually left there unless a search port
you know lesser searches the indexer
it's a for document search database they
left the port open to the world
guess what happens people can go in
there and just select and select star
right
dump out a whole bunch of data so that's
it those are the things you have to
watch out and can you really trust you
infrastructure after you run tens of
thousands of assets in the cloud how do
you know if not an insider or somebody
else already winding and implanted
something right so there's a in the
industry there's another overused phrase
phrase right now it's called zero trust
right really means you rehydrate you
don't trust it you basically run the
service with your your systems for let's
say three months then you destroy
everything and restart redeploy because
it's in the cloud because everything is
infrastructure is called you can you can
do that you can actually manage to do
that
you know old days it's impossible you
have to unrack all the servers and redo
the OS it doesn't work that anymore it
that way anymore
with with the cloud you could have the
ability to have that zero trust kind of
mythology and basically be able to
rehydrate your entire workloads so also
there are two different personas that I
that I described here so the guy on the
left is software engineer we have a lot
of them at Barracuda and we have like
maybe a much smaller number of security
professionals because every company is a
software company it's almost it's almost
like that now right so everyone is
building software doesn't matter if your
bank your Walmart you you're building
software so these guys are trying to
build fast
and when they feel fast they use public
cloud because that's the best way to get
things going
in fact in in with in Barracuda I have a
joke it says friends don't let friends
build data centers because it's really
hard to build it's really hard to
compete with guys like Microsoft Amazon
right so you go build software you build
it fast but security and
clients has to be remain on the top
agenda because that you know with all
the privacy laws that's already around
gdpr is one of them you're gonna have to
make sure you're in the right posture
you have to have continuous compliance
monitoring to make sure you can't sell
your software to other people right so
the problem with these two is there's
inherent kind of friction between them
one wants to go fast one wants to slow
you down okay so so that's why I wanted
to make sure you guys remember these two
personas it's really what's driving the
digital transformation to public law and
and right now I will say sometimes they
win sometimes they win but really they
both have to think about security right
so the cloud secreting clouds not about
building a firewall secreting clouds
about making sure using the cloud
correctly you're utilizing the native
services correctly if there's miss
configuration and it had this happen in
the past one of the engineers probably
needed to have access at home because
they wanted to build fast and build all
the time right so what happened is you
open a security group port you know
today's is just a port number and you
know pour 22 and you basically you know
let the port open and guess what a you
know Amazon was throw a fit because
immediately it was detect that's abuse
and a lot of times if you're not using
strong password it can become a part of
a botnet right so so it's important to
pay attention to these two personas and
everything we built has to revolve
around them and so they allow them to
build fast but constantly check and
balance make sure they don't have any
configuration problems and that's cloud
security actually so this is what a sort
of one example of it so we we do have a
product or cloud security Guardium but
what it is is ingest telemetry from the
cloud environment because just like
normally every system emits some type
some type of security logs right you
think of you know syslog in you know
days but you know telemetry comes from
like cloud trail you know activity log
from as
they all can be ingested and that will
give you an indication of what happened
in your environment and from the earth
then we can actually talk to the cloud
provider using their native API s and
describe what's in the environment
programmatically not manually right po
climatically then we get all that
information that we can actually provide
a visibility to your environment and
eventually identify you know this is the
normal behavior of using you know your
servers running this way at this level
of CPU load is correctly if it goes
beyond that maybe something else is
happening to the system so generally
this is what we're doing as we are
prepared for public cloud level security
so it's very different from the
traditional hump Ram firewalls so you
know in three different states right
emotion arrest and use so in motion
obviously the data is transmitting
through as you can see bear could have
provided solutions like that so firewall
will be a good product to protect data
in motion or web application firewall or
email security gateway because it's a
data plane where MTA their arrest is
basically wences lensing as three
pockets or in your storage devices you
want to make sure that data is secure
right or malware can come in the same
way it's good files how do you make sure
you get get rid of them quickly you use
is tricky because if you are actually
running its company news sometimes is
you're you're manually touching it like
using using a to author to change the
data but a lot of times it's really just
part of the program it's in memory right
it's getting you know handled between
functions and routines so so in that
situation reverse proxies proxies it
actually has the ability to look at your
memory segments and understand what
objects are going in and now it's
important so so what happened to Equifax
I wanted to bring this out is just to
show how bad the situation is right so
when when the struts vulnerability was
discovered I think it's the CVE 2017 56
when this was discovered you know was
kind of out there but so so bad guys
actually gain access
shortly after like I'm less than two
months roughly about two month then once
they gain access to didn't do anything
nobody knew anything for literally about
three months no one
Equifax paid attention and understood
they were breached until sort of end of
July then they kept their silence right
then I tried to clean up quickly I'm
trying to figure out what the damage is
and at the end is 143 million records
that includes our driver's license
includes our previous addresses were
lifting our sibling themes birthdays
right social security number the worst
of all just in July this year I think
they were asked to pay seven hundred
million dollars right - as damages yeah
so that said Equifax this is a really
good example of how insecure the
environment you know you will imagine a
credit you know sort of score company
that keeps your credit it should be very
secure they may have to laugh but I'm
telling you to propagate it and turn it
down into active mode they were just
afraid to break it so this is a study
with it this year so far this year
fifty-minute municipalities already got
attacked by ransomware right so I
there's a few I paid the ransom some
other guys didn't want to pay the ransom
but then pay the higher pricing
recovering the data so the reason here
is that I think the bad guys are
targeting the cities because there are a
lot of sensitive data in the in the
cities government agencies and actually
very important data right so and
obviously we have a solution just to
think about how to really make sure you
are backed up all the time when
ransomware attacks you don't want to pay
the ransom because when you pay you
you're supplying them with more money
and they
new campaigns what's worse is
cybersecurity insurances out there now
so they're demanding higher higher pay
because the insurance companies probably
got deeper wallets right it's cyclical
pretty bad problem okay so I mentioned a
whole bunch of Technology I want to
bring out the story I noticed there may
be a couple folks from Asia if you have
you guys know this who this person is
any guess he's to go down right any of
you guys speak Mandarin or no okay so
he's the Imperial Chancellor so the
reason I want to bring this story up is
I wanted to find out have you guys think
about what what else we can do with data
so here's the Imperial Chancellor in Han
Dynasty many years ago and his job was
to defend his his King for sure but the
problem is he was giving a task to
actually gather a hundred thousand
arrows because he was at at the beach
and the attacker ciaochao you guys
probably know very powerful Imperial
leader was about to take them down right
so his jobs to get a hundred thousand
arrows you don't have hundred thousand
arrows you're in an island right so
actually this story called Red Cliff the
Battle of the Red Cliff it's uh it's
actually available on DVD you can find
the movie and watch it it's spectacular
it's beautiful but the story here is
that he eventually figured out how to do
this because one of the three days that
he was given three days one of the three
days was foggy so he rode out he
actually got all the boats together
stream them up with a straw you know
covering on top so it's basically you
know covered the boat and he went out to
town and just kind of intimidated him
say hey we're coming after you making
noise right so what does toss out do he
shoots arrows at him she collected
hundreds more than hundred thousand
arrows went back home now he has the
weapon from the adversary to protect
himself so the next day that that their
attack actually failed because of this
the reason I wanted to bring the story
out is what can you do with data right
so bad guys are a constantly creating
malware and have you guys any of you
guys have gone through security
awareness training have you have you
guys you have seen that right and the
problem which program did you use spies
okay yeah so so the the issue with
security awareness training is that it
it's always simulated people have to
create the content to actually cut to to
cause you to do the wrong thing then
teach you then they figure out how to
how to actually train you the problem
with that is similarly the content is
not that good so what's happening here
in this story is that what if we turn
the bad guys content and disarm it and
turn into training material immediately
right so then you end up getting the bad
guys working really hard everything they
do every weapon they produce we can
actually disarm it and make it available
as training so that's the that's the top
piece that I wanted to learn today is in
the future we can have to figure out
ways to you know not only deception type
of defense but also figure out ways to
to make the bad guys actually suffering
in many ways actually they actually end
up building things then you disarm it
the reason I give you an example it's
hard to actually explain that but if you
look at office documents they're
actually compressed zip files you guys
probably know right the docx
right so if you open it up there are a
bunch of things in there basically it
can be weaponized let's say the bad guys
putting a macro in there the micros job
is to launch a PowerShell in that
situation we can just disarm that
particular macro and still coach the
user right and and that particular
coaching process can be done completely
yeah programmatically yeah so it's more
of a real-time training using bad guys
malware this
think of think of that right so anyway I
wanted to share that with you and that's
my presentation any questions anyone had
any stories to share on cybersecurity
yeah yeah we're the individual colored
segments linearly stacked or expanded in
the graph there is everything it's
logarithmic so basically in Wednesday's
stack together they're basically
representing relative to that particular
line right so so my point there is I
will bring this back second so the
reason I did it using logarithmic so so
you can see other stuff otherwise you
won't see the anything from it's coming
up this one right yeah
so basically this red section represents
a hundred right here then this section
is almost the same size as the red
section is also about hundred yeah so
they're not in the sense where it you
know there's not relative there's
basically static yeah but you can see
here the biggest problem is email I
wanted to share that with you
why emails the first attack surface
because it's so easy to jump into
yeah any other questions any cyber
security events you guys have
experienced
[Music]
anything in the material that you wanted
to ask was it good
oh there's one question I was just
wondering what is the current technology
to in terms of like encryption and
decryption and how to implement this in
a distributed fashion especially in the
context of a GPU computing okay so
you're talking about encryption as in
SSL sort of
right so I think the question is related
to encryption how the content is getting
encrypted right so in those scenarios
are you talking about storage or more on
the flow like for example encryption in
the in the web flow
yeah actually yet yeah my observation
right now completely lack of encryption
in the sense where a lot of a lot of the
IOT they are actually because it's so
expensive they're looking for ways like
for example arm arm is one of the most
used chips compute processors and while
it's able to do encryption but it's not
hardware assisted right it's not ASIC
based mobile traffic from telcos and we
saw most of them most of the app traffic
was not encrypted at that time it was a
similar situation the hardware battery
and in this situation you know any any
time you use utilize anything that's
like a GPU or any battery very quickly
so so I think that the key there is the
communication protocol you can so one of
the things we practice also as you don't
encrypt the entire transport you encrypt
just the payload you can't build you
can't build a way to actually people can
see the content but they don't know what
to do with the content the content
itself is meaningless until it makes it
to the other side right so but in that
case you're doing less work but not no
no work so in that way I will say any
IOT that that's inexpensive and and
probably is not doing the right thing
for encryption and the certificate
management is another nightmare because
certificate can get lost and you can the
the certain Authority can actually be
taken over right so in that situation
like what we do is we have a trust with
our device and the users so the browser
actually trusts pair could assert CA
then you can do thing to things more
locally in the environment so you don't
have to
so you so our box or our physical device
or virtual device
can actually do the encryption locally
in the in the network right that's right
so yeah we we can in that situation you
basically have to row out using a group
policy to make sure our CA is trusted in
that environment but only affects that
around because that cert is different
for every customer right that's CA yeah
so you had I think I think so we have to
find ways to to really kind of change
the game a little bit because look they
have our social security number we might
as well go out there and just show
people you know the thing is they they
can create fake identities right and I
think because of that exposure I will
say post breach of Equifax in that
magnitude we have to realize what we're
dealing with we have to pack our backup
our data we have to make sure we use MFA
so even in my face now a hundred percent
safe right people already figure out how
to do change the sim right to basically
figure out a way to if you see on your
phone say hey someone's you know
changing your sim your Sims no longer
valid someone's actually hacking your
sim right so that's that that's a very
problematic issue too so I think we're
where we have long ways to go but you
have to really understand like for
example the reason I mentioned cloud
Security's different is because app
builders today they're very different
from the old days we not that old days
but you used to build software you used
to compile it then you system test it
right then you put security around it
today people are building in so fast
HTTP is actually a new transport you
know Daisy writes server client software
using UDP TCP protocol now you're
building it with HTTP WebSockets right
so so I think it's it's really important
for us to pay attention how quickly
every company every organization has
software engineers how do you make sure
you know they're secure in the sense of
creating the software yeah yeah yeah
right right I I think that's why even
when you're not intentional because a
lot of times convenience matters so much
you're leaving some software engineers
actually checking their their keys into
github by accident right then guess what
happens when you're checking your keys
and tokens people can you can get access
to your databases and other storage
right so I think as we are becoming more
open to the cyber war building software
building applications getting things
more efficient we have to really think
about how to secure it at the at the
root that's why you know looking at the
cold looking at the infrastructure code
there's a yeah mall for example is the
infrastructure code that basic goes into
every you know orchestration framework
let it be kubernetes or darker compose
or anything like that so you have to
examine the descriptor of the yamo to
make sure you're not opening the ports
you don't you don't want to be opened
right you guys probably know IP tables
in all days you feel like there's a one
layer of defense on IP tables but today
other workloads are continue eyes
there's no physical I mean there's no
place you go typing okay what kind of
data can what kind of ports are open
inbound outbound you know pre-filtering
post filtering right it's all within the
container so it's kind of to me I think
it's it's okay just we have to
Wow
yeah the other way to look at it if
people are paying insurance for
cybersecurity
I think it's an indicator that bad guys
are winning some ways right I don't
think we remember what we should were
they accept our membership ok I got you
that's really interesting yeah
definitely for me right now also I don't
feel like it's an even playing field
because the bad guys ever since
crypto-currency came about they can they
can actually benefit from that very very
efficiently
you know while we are still organizing
figuring out how to defend them with you
know day to day kind of efforts I think
at some point defensive measures and
things we put in place should also be in
the crypto currency kind of economy yeah
so there's a there's a couple companies
out there looking to do that yeah well
in a sense were trying to monetize
defense but using crypto currency as the
transactional platform you know so
things can be more automated
cool great questions yeah all right oh I
think just really kind of know where
your data is to start with because that
I think that is probably the least the
lowest barrier that you can start with
basically make sure you your data is
secured right so what that means is if
you have it on a server in the data
center with the you know web being in
front end for example that's that's
potentially risk you have a database for
example if you have a application server
running in front of it you don't want to
make sure to at least be prepared to
react to a potential data loss on the
personal and like email attack
perspective just really pay attention to
that I will say the message yourself if
it's got links you really have to make
sure the link is pointing to the right
place you know what type of squatting is
a user example type of squatting is it's
basically people create domains using
typos just look at the letter M right
the M if you put R and and next to each
other
it looks like M right right so you to
the naked eye if you're not careful you
will click on that link and you think
you're going to miss this command to pay
your bills but they could easily fake
that and to make sure they capture your
user name and password on the way there
so really pay attention to that and I
think documents anything with active
content line in a document you have to
be very careful like macros or Java
scripts anything like that you know
there I think those are all don't cuss
too much if you're using office 365 they
already have some level of security in
that in that way to protect you yeah
great
thank you for having me guys thank you